hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 1 of on
the end Cicero has torquatus present the
epicurean position and one of the key
ideas that he touches on is the value of
the virtues are the virtues valuable in
themselves or are they instrumentally
valuable and that is the position that
the Epicureans are going to take namely
that the virtues are good because they
lead us to pleasure temperance is going
to be a particularly important virtue
especially since it bears upon the
pleasures of the bodies
Aristotle much earlier had defined
temperance as primarily applying to the
pleasures of food he talks about drink
but we could really extend this to
intoxication in general since with the
Greeks
wine was the main source of intoxication
and the pleasures of sex but it could
also apply to all sorts of other
physical pleasures you know laying
around in bed basking in the Sun having
massages you know and any of those sorts
of what we call creature comforts and it
can also extend to other kinds of
pleasures that we would consider to be
less directly tied to the body like
the pleasures of say indulging yourself
in binge watching shows for hours after
hours
Netflix particularly if they're not
things with a you know interesting plot
or you know really well developed
characters but think about reality TV
which people gaze at for as I've
mentioned hours and hours those things
could fall under the the virtue of
temperance as well and the idea here is
that temperance is important to the
epicurean way of life precisely because
by being temperate and not being
intemperate you are going to assure
yourself of living a life full of
pleasure and is free of pain as possible
correlative Lee if you don't develop the
virtue of temperance you're actually not
going to have that pleasant of a life so
this may throw some people for a loop
when they associate Epicureanism with
you know the old adage of wine women or
song or the more updated you know sex
drugs and rock and roll that is not
actually the Epicurean perspective
because those things are more likely to
get you into problems so why then is
temperance so important well torquatus
begins right off the bat by telling us
that that virtue provides us with peace
of mind and he does use the word peace
there in the Latin and then it provides
us with a certain kind of harmony
concordia and it's worth dwelling on
this for a moment a little bit earlier
in the text and then running throughout
this entire section on the virtues
torquatus is going to stress that
lacking the virtues produces a certain
kind of disharmony and conflict within
the human being not just a conflict with
other people over you know sources of
pleasure or you know of what things that
they want to avoid in order not to incur
pain but also with when within oneself
if you have very strong desires
you know they can end up in conflict
with each other and then you're sort of
intestine battleground as we like to say
so this is a very important end result
how does temperance help us to do that
so he explains that there's there's a
number of different things that
temperance is doing these are certain
functions the first is to be guided by
reason in what to pursue what to choose
and what to avoid what to reject this is
absolutely central and this is common to
virtue ethics in general it's not a
purely at the Kure an idea about
temperance the general idea is that that
you know we should be guided by reason
and that's part of what virtue does in
this case guided by reason in our
selection of virtues or our choices
about which desires that we have to
actually follow out he says that it's
not enough to judge what is right to do
or to leave undone there's a second
feature to it we also need to abide by
the judgments that we make and the word
that he uses there is stuttering
literally to stand to stand in the
judgment rather than then rejecting it
because many people are able to see what
the right thing to do is but then they
don't stick to it he goes on and he says
most most people lack tenacity of
purpose
the resolution weakens and succumbs as
soon as the fair form of pleasure meets
their gaze and they surrender themselves
to their passions failing to foresee the
inevitable results you know what would
be some prime examples of this well
think about food you know you've got a
particular diet that you're sticking to
and you say okay I need to you know only
eat this amount at this meal and then
your friends take you to the buffet and
you can eat as much as you want at the
buffet because it's a buffet right and
you now you're actually posed with the
problem you know what you're supposed to
do you know what reason is telling you
to do and yet it would be nice to have
another plate wouldn't it or you know
you've been so
good lately wouldn't it be good to have
maybe a dessert or even two desserts or
you know you've gotten really good so
it's okay to drink a few alcoholic
beverages with it because you're not
getting drunk after all you're just
enjoying yourself right and part of you
knows that you're you're going against
the resolution the judgement that you've
made but another part of you is saying
hey this would be pleasant and pleasure
will draw us in we might think of
similar things hitting the snooze button
over and over again well specially if
it's a cold morning and you don't want
to get out of bed in the covers or so so
nice when you know that there's work to
be done that if you don't get done
you're not going to have a nice evening
all right these we can come up with
example after example after example of
people who don't stick to their their
their judgments their decisions and
being able to do that that is part of
temperance so being guided by reason
abiding by it he tells us that we have
to engage in a certain kind of
Prudential reasoning by passing up
certain pleasures we enjoy the highest
pleasure prime example of this would be
you know deciding who to have sex with
or who to even try to pursue a
relationship with maybe it's not a good
idea to take you know whatever comes
along whoever comes along whatever
opportunities come come along and to be
a bit more selective right from an
epicurean perspective that would
probably be the prudent thing to do
similarly when it comes to eating when
it comes to drinking or enjoying drugs
right somebody who imagine you walk into
a place and people have laid out a whole
bunch of different drugs and they're
like you can do anything that you want
here nobody's going to get in trouble
you know nobody's surveilling this area
there's probably some drugs where they
could be quite pleasurable but you you
really ought to turn them down from an
epicurean perspective we also by
enduring pains help ourselves to not
have to deal
with greater pains later on it can be
painful to stick to a dietary regime by
the way as a side note the only diets
that really work long-term are ones that
are that are rational all the gimmick
diets sooner or later fail because
they're not really being temperate
they're really being extreme in some way
but sticking to a diet can often be
painful but what does it help you to
avoid later on health problems right
obesity you know high cholesterol high
blood pressure all these sorts of things
that can cause you significant problems
down the line by enduring the pain of
heartache after a bad breakup and not
immediately jumping into bed with the
next available person on tinder you are
probably saving yourself some much
greater pains down the line right we
could come up with example after example
of that as well exercise is another
prime example when you first begin
working out it is not pleasant you know
your body actually rejects it it it's
sore the next day you may find yourself
you know out of out of breath you may
throw up or things like that you feel
terrible but if you stick to it you will
in fact feel better later on you know
your joints your bones will reward you
as you grow older you have the muscle
capacity to do things that you'd like to
do the last thing to think about is is
he talked about some of the wages of
intemperance if you lack temperance then
what are likely to be the results well
disease is one of them there's all sorts
of physical and also mental diseases the
Epicureans thought of emotional problems
as mental diseases that can come with
that loss of fortune you know making
stupid decisions that affect your
finances affect your property disgrace
social opprobrium legal penalties of
some sort now why should these things
matter because these things are actually
unpleasant they take that some of them
are downright pain
full and they take away your capacity to
enjoy other pleasures so interestingly
from the epicurean point of view you
cannot afford to be indulging yourself
in every pleasure that that comes your
way you need to be rather selective and
you need to develop a disposition that
allows you to say no to some pleasures
in order that you can embrace others and
to say yes to some pains in order that
you can reject and avoid other pains
without that you cannot live an
epicurean happy life
you